believe it or not these are the lucky
Venezuelans they're physically able to
get to Colombia to receive Red Cross aid
the post natal checks so crucial for
newborns and their mothers are
non-existent at home these Red Cross
workers are doing the best they can for
these families this family here have
been waiting in the baking heat for
eight hours to be seen this is a
facility they're trying to cater for as
many Venezuelans as they can but they're
overstretched they have the capacity to
see around a hundred and twenty people
per day but far greater numbers come
here seeking help because of
hyperinflation even basic medication is
beyond the reach of most people Gabriela
has traveled hundreds of miles by bus to
cúcuta her chief mission to get
medication for her three-month-old baby
who has a painful ear infection
[Music]
- VP's will have some latina
it's hard she says sometimes you don't
have anything to eat it's very hard
but you're here you've got these things
and your baby's gonna feel better soon
she's breastfeeding so she needs to get
back home as soon as possible
laden with other necessities like
nappies and flour it'll be another six
hours before she's back with her baby
minor ailments are difficult enough but
for children with serious illnesses the
challenges are breathtaking
five-year-old Vicky was diagnosed with
leukemia in Venezuela when she was three
years old do you like coming to this
playground because her mother's mother
is Colombian she was able to come here
for treatment if you had had to stay in
Venezuela what would have happened to
Vicky
no it's so weird I can mean she wouldn't
be with me she says Vicki still loves
the country that couldn't save her
one day she wants to become a doctor and
go back Columbia is doing what it can to
help but its own health care system is
struggling funding for these children's
cancer care comes mainly from the
recycling of bottle tops US aid has
finally arrived at the border these
trucks contain the food and medical
supplies that could save lives but it's
not going anywhere yet Madhu Roe's
makeshift blockade is still in place
Venezuela will not go begging he says
it's a message that could not be more
wildly out of step with the plight of
his people Amanda Walker Sky News cúcuta
Colombia